best week ever that's the focus of
tonight's angle it's not even close this
was the best week of Donald Trump's
presidency on every front he's winning
he's winning on the economy national
security judicial appointments and even
legislatively his policies and his
strategies are working and the American
people are reaping huge benefits if
you're American looking for work this is
a good economy historic on him go on
employment numbers the Trump economy
doing pretty well I've never seen in my
life
and he now has the best cabinet that I
can recall any president having in my
lifetime and as we just discussed on the
show the White House is finally doing
some much-needed housecleaning so keep
it up get rid of the radicals
undermining from within and replace them
with people who believe in your agenda
mr. president who are competent enough
to carry it out for three years the
liberal intelligentsia predicted doom
for Trump's presidency remember at every
turn there's an acknowledgment inside
the Trump campaign that they they don't
know how their candidate can survive
this at this point you've got McGann
talking that many hours one little
anecdote that he tells could cause
Donald Trump a lot of problems are we
witnessing the end of the Trump
presidency I love those clips wrong you
know when Trump delivered the State of
the Union on Tuesday he did so with the
highest approval rating of his tenure at
49% by the way that's higher than
Obama's approval at the same time in
2012 and he easily remember Obama Cruz
to re-election later that year these
were the same geniuses by the way I'm
thinking about it who were predicting
cracks and GOP unity heading into
impeachment would you give a high end of
who would vote for a conviction of
Republicans
I would give the high-end probably five
to ten I think that's a realistic number
there's a chance that there will be 20
Republicans I'm not predicting and I
wouldn't bet on it but I think there's a
chance I think Romney has helped
reassure maybe Speaker Pelosi that there
is the possibility of Republican support
maybe in the Senate okay a good rule of
thumb if Bill Kristol predicts it bet
the other side Oh
Romney was the sole peer defect Oh and
Newt ons now on his head now not only
did Republicans stick together they had
a reason to celebrate it like it was
2016 all over again
oh we didn't really play all da it was
crazy I was in the room that was the
least of the applause but the left
hasn't been right since about 2012 when
you think about it and since then it's
been one bust of a prediction after
another the US economy is growing at an
unsustainable rate wages adjusted for
inflation are actually worse under
Donald Trump than they were under Barack
Obama and yet I keep hearing from people
who say they are still struggling not
quiet kids fresh economic numbers today
show a booming resilient labor market
the economy added 225,000 jobs in the
first month of the year pretty
remarkable 3.1 percent wage growth I
just got to say it at the top the middle
class boom the blue-collar boom
continues these are the good old days
folks and surveys are showing that
Americans are happier than they've been
for four decades even happier than under
Ronald Reagan this is great news for
America which means it's terrible news
for the Democrats
I think congresswoman Debbie Dingell she
might have summed it up best everybody
wants to get out of town today I think
this has been quite frankly in my career
not just here but in my professional
career one of the worst weeks that I can
remember now we all know why the ladies
were wearing white during the State of
the Union
they're already surrendering and that's
the angle